الشتاء ويعقد الامور في الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا وعلى عده مستويات لوجسيا سيصبح
من الصعب نقل القوات والعتاد في الاراضي
المغطاه بالثلوج والوحل وبالتالي سيتعطل
اي مجهود تعبوي
مروحه من شانها ان تجبر القوات الروسيه
والاكرانيه على تثبيت مواقعها الدفاعيه
وتعزيز ما تعرف بحرب الخنادق حرب يتم
تركيز فيها على القصف الصاروخي والمدفعي
وعلى استخدام المسيارات التي تستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعيه لبلوغ اهدافها
ولهذا استبقت القوات الروسيه الشتاء
باستهداف محطات الطاقه وشبكات توزيع
الكهرباء الاوكرانيه
لتحاول خلقه بين الشعب الاوكراني وقيادته
السياسيه كما اشارت له صحيفه الجارديان في
ملف خاصته لتاثير الشتاء على الحرب لكن
هذه المره يبدو انك فتى الشتاء راجحه
للطرفين الروسي والاوكراني معا ف كلاهما
لديه خبره في اداره هذا النوع من الصراعات
الجيش الاوكراني يسترد اراضيه كانت تحت
السيطره الروسيه وبالتالي قطع خطوط
الامداد عن شبه جزيره القرم موقفا بذلك ان
يتقدم كانت القوه الروسيه تنوي القيام به
ومنذ بدايه الحرب وثقت منظمه الصحه
العالميه اكثر من 700 هجوم على مؤسسه صحيه
واذا اخذ بعين الاعتبار تاثر بنيه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه فان المستشفيات ستعجز عن العمل
بكامل طاقتها فلا شيء سيعمل ابتداء من
اقسام العنايه المركزه انتهاء بالمشارح
مرورا بقاعات العمليات
الجراحيهم بحساسيه الموقف اتفق اعضاء حلف
شمال الاطلسي في القمه المنعقده في
رومانيا على زياده دعمهم خلال فصل الشتاء
عبر ارسال مولدات الكهرباء والوقود
ومضادات الطائرات المسيره ومعيدات لحمايه
من البرد لدعم صمود الاوكران العربيه